this book was designed to be as boring
as possible let's take a look inside now
I believe that anything can be
interesting but also anything when done
right can make you drowsy especially if
you write it like this in spirals that
Force the eye to go around and around
and around the book also contains a
catalog of spoons a dictionary of words
to describe dullness here's a selection
of the dullest entries in interesting
diaries for example on September 2nd
1938 George Orwell wrote in his Diaries
fine and fairly warm oh
metric and Imperial measurements of
screws there's also activities for
example count the Sheep
count the Sheep again or how about a
Spot the Difference game which of these
sweaters is different here's a history
of the Snellen eye chart written like an
eye chart
oh and I'll leave you with this one
pause the video to see how well you do a
staring contest with 48 cats